ora che sono arrivato fin qua ci ho
messo un anno e mezzo se sbaglio la mira
non ce la farò mai più
[Musica]
i ragazzi prevenuti aver solo video sono
vari geni sono parati solamente ragazzi
mancano pochissimi livelli al finale che
sarebbe questo che però non ci arriverò
mais tipo nuovo il culetto quasi tre
settimane che non facciano episodio di
grande ed infatti sono carichissimo ace
il muro che mi viene addosso a sa cosa
non avevo capito
c'è quindi quindi vado devo andare devo
correre prima che mi prendono bene non
vedo un cazzo vai vai vai vai veloce
mio zio è impossibile come faccio a far
star no vabbè non è impossibile
madonna cosa ho fatto al primo tentativo
al primo tentativo non è vero non è vero
madonna è impossibile ci devi correre un
chilometro e mezzo dai secondo tentativo
sarebbe già record ragazzi per chi
inventa di giochi che mi fanno incazzare
perché non possono fare dei giochi belli
forza sono solo veloce come un tricheco
fantastico è partito un braccio ma per
chi se ne frega a chi ha bisogno di
braccia me ne fotto vai vai vai a lecce
ho fatta sì non è vero non è vero non è
vero
ragazzi uccido qualcuno oggi uccido di
giro ammazzo datemi qualcuno ad
ammazzare che subito si no dopo ok ok
grazie a dio
fammi andare a società può intuire che
ammazzò veramente qualcuno perfetto
perfetto
stavo cadendo a eminflex anno non sono i
materassi e una bistecca perché fate del
forno sulle piste che va beh sì che
comunque guardando uno show tipo dove
uno zombie si squarta in mille pezzi che
vuole ho fatto che cazzo ne servi
guardando uno show dove uno zombie si
squarta in mille pezzi e viene proprio
voglia di comprare la carne veramente
dai dai dai dai veloce madonna veloce
dove devo andare in filo dei miei film
di madonna mi si è fermato che se non si
fermavano moltissimo che busone culo non
ha idea del culo se vuoi s ma io non ce
la faccio più devo arrivare al check
point ragazze crepon tre podi fisso ma
convinto proprio che non ce la faccio ai
vai vai
ok oddio ti ringrazio dio per michela è
impossibile veramente cos'è abello
picchiare ha tranciato bello questo che
ti arrivano i razzi addosso i laser ciò
ancora una gamba mi chiama salti come un
ameba zio la barca era ok siam partiti e
son riuscito anche solo a parte non li
vedo là dove arrivano non avevo visto
dove andare di qua perfetto modo vado
torna indietro come faccio che ciò è
così dietro come fa devo andare a culo
ok ok donandoli perfetto
poi ci ho fatto ragazzi il suo livello
sta avendo un culo incredibile dove vado
addio
ok ok sì sì gol ce l'ha fatta
ce l'ho fatto finito nove minuti per st
kucka 9 da martellarsi maroni shadow of
the row a questo boss scende all of the
global messo salve
ciao a tutti grazie grazie di essere
venuti piove piove ma chissenefrega
tanto ci sarà del sangue devo battere un
robot ma dove sta secondo roba di
madonna ma cos'è e vabbè ma che
esagerazione regate lanciarla testa là
dentro c'è scritto non entrare ma io la
faccio entrare lo stesso mancata ma
[ __ ] better ma dai che mira brutta
frate ma guarda lì che inutile o mi fate
entrare in quella [ __ ] finestra per
fare niente o non so la mira oggi ma
qualche inutile
guardavo doveva dove vai dove vai
cosa sta tra l'altro non l'ha preso non
mi ha preso non so come o miglia
mezz'ora dalle boe deve ucciderti
dispiace
ucciso qualcosa ho ucciso qualcuno
perfetto ho schiacciato il tasto ho
capito cosa ho vinto prove posso uscire
grazie è stato bello sbloccato qualcosa
non ho capito cosa provi a ok adesso
posso andare su ha quindi ogni piano
deve entrare nel nel buco perfetto
quindi se riesco a entrare da lì
porca vacca quasi lebron james lebron
quasi cazzo del regno corpo imperfetto
chi che possa recuperare il porco dai
fra tema donna ma porca eva devi morire
ho già ucciso due uomini ragazzi nel
mentre c'è rendetevi conto ragazzi non
rispondenti a centrare la finestra da
dentro c'è figuriamoci da fuori il corpo
il corpo ancora lì che fu lo siamo
arrivati al 5 c'è poi ragazzi e 2 vado
lì sopra obladì obladà e va beh
ora che sono arrivato fin qua ci ho
messo un anno e mezzo se sbaglio la mira
non ce la farò mai più
fatemi c'entra il ragazzo de finestra si
teneva affanculo aggrapparsi e grazie ho
preso non è vero non è vero non è vero
non è vero non è vero non è vero non è
vero non è vero comunicato c'è conto non
è vero infatti e toccare il checkpoint
percorsi siano vi chiedo nient'altro che
sotto care il check point ha levato cosa
c'è aiuto che cazzo è il nostro vivo
sono il nostro vino visto strisciando
cassa c'è un laser che mi segue online e
cosa devo fare
sì ci ho fatto l'ho saltato l'ho saltato
non avrò mai più st occasione ve lo dico
ragazzi sono un unico adesso perso ma
aveva un culo l'ho distrutto
ma devo ma che cazzo lo sapevo io dalla
stanza segreta il minchione che ne so
ragazzi incredibile e increscioso dio ti
ringrazio solo 14 ore e mezzo chi milita
14 ore della mia vita non nessuno eh
vabbè che grazie alla scala gentilissimi
guardaroba indecente ragazzi non vi non
ci posso che io ho tagliato tanto io ho
fatto vedere solo le parti migliori ma
ho tagliato tantissimo ma non avete idea
di quanto mi sia come grazie ben bene
sono stato ma [ __ ] perfetto ci ha
messo una di 35 minuti e 35 fottutissimi
minuti ii livello quanto avete visto
come due minuti quanto ci metti a
evitare i video file di 5 minuti ma
[ __ ] impossibile ma impossibile
dai facciamo 16 sprinter spinter almeno
se questo qua ci mettiamo cinque minuti
l'uno non è subito di 6 ore almeno
quelli ranking che mario è una roba così
c'è mai successo perfetto ce l'ho fatta
da che parte bene so che già è difficile
così figurati se devo anche scegliere la
parte madonna come ha fatto che lascia
il pezzo di legno questo qui fa cascare
allora salto prima per altro pezzo di
bello è che non capisco a che distanza è
quindi boss alto così perfetto perfetto
vai vai vai vai vai c'è poi dovrei
social point grazie dove eccolo giu
no no sapevo regalo sapevo come cazzo
sono rimasto nova ma ci credete non
facciamoci domande va bene così perfetto
che ho fatto ragazzi non ci posso
credere è stato assurdo point ragazzi
andiamo grazie grazie
altro giro altra corsa ok madonna non ce
la farò mai più a tornare qui se il film
io muoio muoio
invece noi invece lo invece noi che
c'erano dove cazzo vai doveva solo
andare il dritto avevo vinto è facile
questa parte perché non ci riesco invece
sì ce l'ho fatta ma torna così a pezzi
di legno vai vai come come come come
come come madonna
cosa ho fatto dai dai laici sono non lo
rifarò meglio i ragazzi non lo rifarò
meteo ragazzi facciamo l'ultimo perché
sennò poi michele diventa lunghi stato
registrato da due ore e mezza prova 28
ce la faccia su carta ok parliamone che
vogliamo fare di 20 ragazzi devo andare
a memoria cosa che non so sapete tutti
che cio alzheimer quindi come faccio
[Musica]
ma si vede quelle che vanno distrutte se
guardo bene si vede allora no niente ho
capito spero spero poi alla fine non è
così che tipo quella di mezzo adesso
verrà distrutta anno verrà distrutto
tutto hanno fatto apposta a mettere
stato di casa hanno valutato che la
gente che giocava tanto sto gioco è
arrivato a sto punto spaccava tastiera e
quindi hanno deciso di mettere siamo
così che hanno fatto bene è un gradino è
se hai voglia di superarlo fammelo
sapere devono essere check point che
aspetto che vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai mai vero e ce l'ho fatta
non è vero non è vero non è verde
salta bravissimo ce l'ho fatta ancora
questo e poi ho vinto
se sei così facile ma non penso l'ultimo
me lo sai che non lo sa benissimo però
non sono riusciti
ragazzi siamo arrivati a un punto in cui
devo correre ok se arriva alla fine bene
se non arriva alla fine mi ammazzo via
[Musica]
poi si dio santo benedetto non ce la
posso più fare la gara è stato è assurdo
veramente ciò mi è venuto mal di testa
non sto scherzando venuto mal di testa
ma che ora che so li spero che vi sia
piaciuto io sono stato molto contento di
giocare a grande ed infatti mi è
piaciuto molto si vede dalla faccia
perché consente ragazzi servito è
piaciuto momento mi piace ovviamente
qualcuno c'ha un occhi per cortesia mi
piace per far passare il mio mal di
testa anzi mi piace per farmi aumentare
che è meglio anche a faccia di facebook
con il fratello iscrizione serie tv di
sky tv ci vediamo proseguito dei ragazzi
[Musica]